hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pony island now we
just woke up from an indeterminate
amount of time assuming that we did go
back to the same machine which may or
may not be true we may have been blown
back because I remember in the foggy
waking up there was one machine in the
distance that was offline so it's
entirely possible we're just at a
different machine in the same arcade but
it also is really interesting that
there's an arcade in the afterlife and
maybe this is just one part of a greater
scheme of things it's not like I was
forced to go back there was a little
arcade cabinet that Ed prizes next to it
so either way there's a lot of mystery
here oh it's the new mascot how you
doing
howdy friend my name's lovey and this
here is called Pony island you will play
as a beautiful Pony frolicking and
leaping over gates but enough talk
let's give it a try is that my computer
here come some gates flick the left
mouse button Oh what if I don't
oh I failed hey I just can't do it
hey hey hey yeah where's my laser
where's my super laser that I shoot out
of my face hole any news on that one
lovey or are you Louie
he might be Louie he might not be loving
love you might have been a stupid name
hold down the right mouse button to blow
a gust of air you'll need it
to blow away butterflies ha ha ha ha to
stop them from tickling
oh it's so cute whoosh uh whoosh Oh foo
ha ha man it's so cute oh oh I I
remember that sound effect from earlier
in the game we oh I have magical wings
getting a little ahead of ourselves
you didn't even let me explain that one
ah ha ha ha it's ok ok
[Music]
like how when I'm in the air got a
stubby little ball sac hanging off of me
I'm sorry to interrupt all the niceness
with my crude vulgarity up the food Oh
movie Oh movie oh so cute cut yeah how
long do I got to do this Louie Louie Oh
Oh huh um I'm a murmur
you win looks like it's time for a a
puzzle break oh no not this again we
we've got ourselves a puzzle here do we
now the goal is I'm aware of what the
goal is buddy boo wait how do i okay an
eye I know what to do hey III Goats it
there we go okay magical play
I know I know I know I know I know I
know I know so pretty I know I know
ah first oh there we go alright you
might need this
Oh
[Music]
okay oh that's funkalicious which
butterfly gets go home just get someone
home oh oh my god
the clone conundrum oh well that's no
good
how do I get them all the way over
though is the question put this here
lamb okay so two butterflies don't get
to go home but then what did that say
that was something there there was
something there would here or something
here huh
uh what about what happens if I just
keep creating more over here what's
gonna happen doubled it
but it ah that's what needed to happen
oh that needed to go over there and then
did the dog a Oh joyous day hello I I
saw that wow you're really smart
thanks I know I tell myself that all the
time I just wait and hope that my mother
tells me the same okay does this what is
hello oh it may be best to not touch
those yeah I don't know we're talking
about I seem to be doing just fine touch
your nose
okay where that's whoosh all right fine
what happens if I don't touch those are
they gonna come after me
[Music]
they're like landmine butterflies but
butter mines something like that lie
mines flutter mines that's a good one
I lose okay almost there thank you for
guiding me to this victory you are just
the best Louie the Blues that was going
on in the background there Louie Louie
why does this all seem to be falling
party or Louie maybe you could give me
an explanation Louie as to where I went
and why I am here ah damn it and monk
victory is mine ho unlock Premium mode
blaze forehead to screen to release soul
I don't know if I can do that I'll take
that ticket though thank you thank you
I'll take that um I don't know if I I
can I can try I think I'm okay did you
guys enjoy my soul please take good care
of it okay hi oh uh uh uh
just just little confused as you what
the heck is going on and why I'm what
why am i why am i blowing I killed you
know I didn't know there was literally
what that was I wanted to make a guess
but I wasn't 100% sure
oh man I mean you can't put that in the
game and then criticize me for falling
the [ __ ] Louie
oh hello I yeah okay there's no hiding
this time I think it's time for another
puzzle break a break puzzle a break
Buzzle oh boy oh boy oh boy Brad huh oh
dang it dingus dang it
hopefully someone gets to go home no
dang it ha-ah
I beat your system oh I thought I'd be
yours as Dom okay this is gonna do it
yeah this is gonna do it okay this is
this this is gonna do it yeah this
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] off there we go okay
that was easier than I thought I'm just
stupid I'm just incredibly incredibly
stupid what's going on over here okay I
made it through eventually just by sheer
magnitude of clone Ajay got through
there okay but a Louie thing seems to
Sylvie broke Stinson's I don't know if I
should be either a lot worried or
moderately okay at the comfort of her
toe my wigs are different Rama Marilyn
oh hi Jesus how you doing good to see
you again
I suppose oh [ __ ] I flew the wrong floof
gotcha again ah Lily I'm at the end of
the level I don't know when it lit hi
Louie what is going on okay just stop
you already beat fun levels uh
[Music]
me to do nothing I was just trying to
have fun
ah is another puzzle we're gonna crop
this over 166 uses doodlee doodlee
doodlee doodlee doodlee doodlee no [ __ ]
okay so we just can't have that at okay
guliguli I know I know what's going on
here okay I got a guy god I gotta get it
I get it
so now we got to go this way we're gonna
Ram laminate blam oh hi oh hi oh hi why
am I in lost souls area messenger works
fine Pony Island and plate as soon as
I'm able I will open a portal for you
the corrupt bro
this is the last thing they said to me
it's a portal gen security exception
okay
logout can't do that okay it seems like
this hasn't been touched for a long long
time there's got to be a way out of here
besides this thing Oh
clicking on a face in the background
that's a thing like someone's been here
for a long time oh hi okay ah it's an
order thing three okay I saw the little
ticket over there oh not the ticket I
saw the little thing over there
little faces okay so I got that but that
wasn't to get out of here I just solved
an even different puzzle 3 3 1 + 3 3 5
equals 6 6 6 2 at Edmonton noob do I
type in here hello
331 years 135 you've slept for centuries
I have a truth to tell you you're not
the only trapped soul there are
thousands like you they did not
surrender to Lucifer and false screaming
into hell but they are stuck all the
same perhaps on a puzzle perhaps on a
level you have destroyed two of the
three core files if you are still
resolved I will help you find the third
that is the recycling bin okay in there
you can find the pony islands of old
versions of the game that he created and
then discarded search through the
discarded games find me a place where I
can place a portal to the final core
file I think I made myself clear
okay I still can't get out of here help
I can't leave I can't leave and I don't
oh right there oh let's go to boney
Island 3d I'll bet that's fun
I'm ready bring it home
uh-huh it's not even seitan like its
system tech in 3d Wow nice oh look at
that oh that's lovely
whoo crack credits where credit and
water something cross finger point
that's what it says down there I don't
know
whoa oh my god well it's 3d I suppose
oh that's okay can I prove can i blast
my lays are oh boy
I'm a bit of a track here Oh God what
okay everything's gonna be fine I'm just
a little pony oh oh ah I can't believe I
failed it that early I am just that
terrible but don't worry I know what I'm
doing maybe a little bit I did it
insert your soul now to upgrade to 40 I
don't think I can open the portal here
come back to the desk up we'll try
another one okay corrupted how about
text Pony Island I get to have a typing
event I used to love text-based games
like love love love them because they
were pure imagination and you had to pay
attention like really close attention to
all the details
oh cool continue yes
[Music]
attractive menu appears Oh
- beautiful ponies accompany the text
Pony Island oh the many buttons hold
such promise how about we go to the
credits his credits fly by you were
filled with awe one name stands out
among the rest Lucifer you return to the
main menu with a newfound appreciation
for developers the many buttons holds
such promise options a vast array of
options are displayed anti-aliasing
cheerful facade Oh free ticket can I get
a free ticket thank you I got a free
ticket one zero one zero zero one one
zero one zero obscure options you click
the option at beeps but nothing happens
okay probably no none of these are gonna
work besides free ticket start start
game air roar OH
so I do got to go into the options okay
so something in the options is here what
about the fix Start menu
but what did it do ah it's like the
beginning of the game okay so go back
and then we can start the game it fixed
the Start menu which we're gonna be able
to do starred game I was one of the
things about the slow premises is
loading a screen well programmed loading
screen looks very quickly okay very
quickly the game is loaded in you're a
pony beautiful sunsets over some perfect
green hills it look like a but you feel
the wind through your Mane as you gallop
across a grassy field hark I wouldn't
gate approaches you jump how about we
jump you leap majestically over the gate
but another gate approaches do you jump
I jump over the gate clear it and run
straight Oh an enemy I better shoot
lasers pour from your mouth and fire at
the enemy obliterating it another gate
might be a little too far away do you
jump how about we do nothing for the
moment you allow the gate to get closer
ah what a clever boner you are looks
jumpable now let's jump it we're an
expert at this adventure here you jump
over and feel smart for waiting at all
shimmering flag post approaches do you I
will jump for joy didn't matter your
neck brick Oh
I'm the reason I'm freaked out right now
is that that like changed the
perspective of every single time I hit a
flag post cuz throughout the entire game
every single time I had that black ball
that pony died half is a different pony
oh that's one of those uh oh okay I
didn't know that
oh boy cuz that was an accurate
description of everything that happened
in the games before oh boy here we go
was the opening sequence up there we are
oh it's it's lovely I've gotten 11 oh
boy
well let's keep going then something
tells me that's not what we're looking
for
oh boy devil island last one Oh
[Music]
ah yes let's go full seitan why not rude
Lucifer sole proprietor who needs any
business partners when you're in hell
I'm okay credits I made it me the devil
I make games people talk [ __ ] cuz I
don't have a high conversation rate of
players conversion to soul sacrifices
wait but it's not all about that the
salts are just a way of counting on a
people like the game if they just told
me they liked it about enemy needs souls
remember okay ah [ __ ] don't work
oh what a well programmed loading screen
oh oh I've got all my powers but when I
Ram into the flag post now I know the
horrible truth that literally is one of
those moments where it's like a horrible
horrible truth yeah so fun to understand
all this to correctly I obviously I die
the person who's playing this right now
is dead and is stuck here and this is
some weird version of purgatory where
the devil's trying to collect his do by
convincing people to play his games and
that's what's gonna convert people over
to hell but apparently there's a way out
oh here we go dead death success insert
your soul or souls to play as the Pony
this will work the security is weak Here
I am opening the portal this is it my
friend
I hate it when people call me my friend
the last core file it's always a little
sinister right hi Asmodeus how are you
doing
hello I can't read all of that hello
good morning would you like to play a
game at last you have me you will find
in my way I to be more sophisticated
than the other demons I am going to play
again with you one I have never lost the
rules are simple your eyes on me if I
catch you looking away you lose also if
you answer my questions incorrectly you
lose hey my name Asmodeus Oh
now say something a little bit
disgusting with a bit of a bit of no
wrong answers form with this one ah say
something the fire okay who will be but
P boopy boopy boopy move about me like I
said no wrong answers nananananana
nananananana nananananana mission I was
legitimately concerned I was going like
Oh someone messaged me am I gonna wait
hey on I was oh god I looked away
oh god somebody still paying attention
I'm playing attention yes type that
phrase for me oh god damn it I was
fooled I was fooled by it I thought that
Oh God ah god damn it I legitimately
thought I was like in my mind I was like
oh no this is coming up on my recording
I gotta edit that out I was like ah [ __ ]
ah god damn it it got me and it got me
good this sack of [ __ ] ah poopy butt bee
boo be boo boo be boo was it was it boo
be boo you lose
Oh bah ha my face like I said no wrong
answers okay the next thing I want you
to do is to just type a phrase for me
just the phrase infernal okay I got it
now infernal
oh Jesus type that phrase for me okay
I'll do that
Inferno okay I got ya that's tricky
you're tricky one I may have
underestimated you but now I insist
apologize to your friend
what you said was not very nice
no hahaha your typing speed of 24 words
per minute indicating you were on the
[ __ ] perhaps you are not now here is an
easy one
which horse like animal appears the most
commonly in this game which animal uh
hang a whole rabbit a burner that one
looks friendly oh it does look at it
jump I don't wanna look at it
smile No Oh to be asked every hat that
mony to be unburdened by intellect I
jest did you look away no what was
written below me what was written below
you what which one are you talking about
Asmodeus exeunt Asmodeus dot exe you
know why idea what you're talking about
I was looking right at you correct
oh geez remember this Oh
I gotta pay more attention I've got two
black marks on my soul okay this time
I'm gonna pay two after I get this one
remember this remember this got it you
are focused yes this time ah you have a
phenomenal ability to follow
instructions okay but how is your memory
remember this sequence
[Music]
okay I know what it is just waiting for
anything to stop it what
what
ah wait what no I let me wait talking
about Wow what are you talking about you
did a fake you did a fake in crash you
faked the game crash no no no no oh you
did it again you did again you did again
you did it again you did it again so
this is this is not real
ah - OH -
well ah see okay I knew it I knew it I
knew it
BAM I knew you were [ __ ] with me I
just ended up actually cause game I will
allow you to destroy this core file will
you know am ia as far exceeded its
original purpose after nothing but
pondering for centuries death will be a
great adventure momentum in the farewell
I don't think this is true well I don't
I don't I don't know about this
we're vials of glow blah blah blah bye
yes oh is that really it Oh
shouldn't have been that easy Oh bun
Meghan are we well I have no idea what's
going on here
welcome to recovery mode oh boy oh hi
hello you have done well and now it is
almost over when you are ready perform
the system dumb there will be nothing
left afterwards and you will be freed
your soul will not be safe as the system
is dumping you will need to stay ahead
of it
I have prepared a family of familiar
vessel for this purpose ah
one final Pony run myself we will meet
again once all is said and done but this
is a game and you want to beat it right
so go and claim your victory
okay we're gonna dump this [ __ ] hard
souls that have been trapped
imprisoned and embarrassed tormented and
mocked maddened with frustration now is
the time to rise you'll see you're here
oh boy run with the speed of 1000 Oni
and be free oh my god
what holy [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] oh we got to
avoid those oh my god
Oh get him out of here clear him out
play around flermin yeah I'm not gonna
lose to too many more ponies I've lost
some but yeah sorry oh my god so many
ponies this is the most intense last
Pony run of my life can't believe I've
lost three souls already but three seems
to be the number of things that I always
lose good thing I got an unlimited barge
oh man I could have got I could have
gotten through this with no ponies lost
damn it Oh deleting enemy lot oh hey ah
seems like this might be a problem
okay I can do love
there we go okay you don't want to give
me your souls fine I am no longer asking
oh hi
final boss Sam oh boy oh hey ah geez I
didn't I wasn't for okay maybe I
couldn't have gone through this with all
my ponies intact cuz I meant how do I
avoid that impassable oh my god
can't lose enough Souls oh Jesus
it's impossible holy [ __ ] no my ponies
ponies hey come on now god damn it
good thing I got a new pony everyone's
allowed to take over as leader so many
people want to pick up the flag carry an
effort I've done horrible horrible
errors oh yeah I'm only 50% of the way
there holy [ __ ] is gonna take forever oh
I almost forgot
an old friend wanted to say goodbye
oh you killed me he killed me yeah I
know you got in the way in my laser oh
oh oh I see how it is oh I see how it is
this is zombie Louie over here watch out
for his burps of doom
God so many ponies how many souls were
lost in this whole smorgasbord ah alas
you truly deserve this that one would
deserve what what an epic victory as I
get the fudge out of here don't I
deserve because I'm pretty sure that's
true well over here dick hole pen loser
Oh what's happening oh the screen is
breaking oh geez you think this is
simulated in Pony form so that everyone
would be able to get through the nary a
problem in the world well there went the
walkthrough Wow the blast in my pony
gold yeah get him get him
damn apart ah hell yeah
we just kill them Oh
very good oh man all the screen edges
are starting to break it's like the end
of the matrix when all the cracks
started hearing aids of Smith's face and
he was just exploding with power and
death he was exploding with death well
oh they're getting free all their be
freed they made it I mean a few didn't
and sucks for them but I guess after an
eternity being trapped in a weird arcade
cabinet from the early 70s or 80s Wow oh
I'm rising
I'm ascending holy [ __ ] ah oh oh oh pony
oh oh that was amazing oh I love that oh
I love that so much that was amazing in
every way that was so cool
from start to finish that was an awesome
idea I now realize I was looking way too
much into this because obviously it's
just a game and a meta informational
thing about a game but I wonder what
kind of new things would happen if you
got all of the tickets because I did not
get all the tickets I was close I just
didn't get all of the tickets now who's
to say if there actually is a story at
the end of it but it was fun to kind of
ponder what exactly was going on because
in the end I was right about the the
cave of truth and it's questions it
doesn't really matter who you are but
there are secrets to this game and your
soul in the game was freed when you beat
it but mine will be trapped for as long
as pony island's rotten bits sit on your
hard drive I have been carefully guiding
you
from the beginning moving you toward
this moment knowing that if you did not
complete the game you may never
uninstall it so please do it delete Oni
Island save my so I'm gonna I'm gonna
delete it and I'm gonna reinstall it ah
[Music]
oh wow okay so there's an act select so
I'm assuming this is to be easier to get
tickets now I only have 11 of 24 which
means that I don't have everything that
I need but maybe I'll get there someday
I just won't do it in this episode here
and maybe I'll revisit it at some point
to get those juicy little secrets but
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching I really hope you enjoyed
this I had a ton of fun with it it's a
really imaginative game and I think it
deserves a lot of praise so thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]
I can still through this yes I liked how
I did a 180 from being like this is
horrible - yeah